super bedbug the whole idea is we know
what it's like when you differentiate
something you get the derivative but
what you try to go in the reverse
direction when you're trying to age a
different shape when trying to work out
the primitive not the derivative right
it's a little bit different number one I
mean the process is in Reverse and can I
just make a note right now that you know
what differentiation is and if you will
be going through this person is all sort
of addressing it I just want to give you
a heads up that they are very easy to
confuse with each other okay
and I promise the vast majority of you
if you're normal people like me you will
go to a period where you'll be answering
a question you'd be like wait which one
am i doing it right and you accidentally
do one instead of the other I just want
you to pause every time good morning
pause every time you do were these
questions that say okay now which one am
i doing there for which way did the
powers go like when you're
differentiating just deal with
polynomials we get to trigonometric
heads and Exponential's and log
functions later on were you dealing with
Exponential's differentiating takes the
power down road anti-differentiate it
takes the power up okay so this is the
first example that we looked at so let's
just have a crack at this right I'm very
support I've got this guy right I know
how to differentiate this the derivative
of this which would give me good boy the
second derivative would just be to just
be - okay but now I want to try and go
in the opposite direction so you go
through one term at a time so firstly I
I would say y equals and when I have it
look at this there's two steps that I'm
after are raise it to power and then
divide by whatever your new power is you
send it again make sure you divide by
the new power don't do the division
first okay so let's have a look to X
when I increase the power which is
currently one if you can debate x
squared - this is two x squared and then
I divide right divided
- okay now you can see I have chosen to
X because you like I've seen this a lot
of time before and that those twos are
going to cancel right you knew in fact
hurtfully you recognize that what you
differentiate it to get to X what is
just x squared so very frequently these
two so we'll just cancel out okay but
watch out you don't always which is why
I'm putting the twos down so you see the
kids Lee happens explicitly I'm not
finished yet so good morning I'm 80
differentiated this term just like when
I do bridge and I go through term by
term if I 80 different yet I also go
through term by term okay
so this plus one here is going to become
plus well I'm going to increase the
power what's the power of that term in
the bedroom it's exit now zero isn't it
so that zero comes up to 1 x2
what can I divide by the new power which
is 1 okay now I've dealt with all the
terms now I add my constant on right
because this is all family of previous
and B this is just this pretty ruler to
come out of there with a wild see up
here okay I should stay I should stay
hey that's it I'm finished so we see
that just like the three other summits
the symmetry to use the agent derivative
the primitive of a sum is the sum of the
prim use of each one okay I'm so glad
you asked that question great question
to us because we start to get at what
what is this state here very astutely of
no display i anti-differentiate of both
of these pieces so you would expect that
i get a constant for each of those
pieces okay
so I could say kind of look I should get
a cluster sorry she's getting closer and
this one I'll call it close to one and
then actually get accustomed for this
one I'll call it constant 2 however
being that they're both clusters they
just numbers when you act
again the two constants unsurprisingly
you got a constant right say in fact
good morning it could be any number of
terms yeah right a number terms any
number of little closets that comes with
each one but when you put the ball in a
big pile they are all still really one
big cluster does that make sense so glad
you put it that out because you knew my
right um I have a different shape each
one so they really should be one each
all over the way but I can put them
together in five okay okay now the the
very natural extension out of this which
we didn't get to look at yesterday is
this is a whole family of primitives
okay now really quickly I shouldn't I
should just simplify that x squared plus
X plus C okay just like we did yesterday
can we just briefly draw this we briefly
draw this as a family of different
graphs so for example one of the graphs
that's in this family is just x squared
plus X where the constant is 0 okay and
we know what x squared plus X it looks
like it has it has two intercepts namely
0 and negative 1 okay because um I would
factorize out there yes so there's my
serie and my negative 1 okay so let's
you control that one so 0 and negative 1
it is a parabola going through here they
go so this is just where the constant is
here but as we know it there's all the
other members of the family where the
closest could be 1 or 2 now just truly
these guys either having the whole
family in the picture it's actually very
helpful
okay at the moment
this life here at that life I don't know
which one of these is the actual
primitive it really can be any of them
however if I get a little bit of extra
information if I know not just what the
graphs derivative is he's the dreamer if
I have a single point that the original
function passes through for instance
suppose either that the function passes
through there okay I no longer have a
family of primitives as options right
there's only a single member of this
whole family that passes through at one
point because all the other ones will be
too high or they'll be to load does that
make sense
so if I know a point that this guy
passes through I could go past there be
sure primitive the one that it came from
that you deep low okay so for instance
just as an extension of this okay so
maybe we'll call this one part one okay
if it putts who I know okay give it that
why that's function of X okay that guy
the primitive that we ended up with
given that that class is food and I'll
just give you an example you can
literally pick obviously G okay the
example I'm picking is passes through
this point negative 2 comma 5 right now
you can find the actual unique primitive
how are we gonna do this well the first
step remains the same okay you would
have had to have AG differentiate at
that and then tada I've got a whole
family okay so this is what Y is equal
to now what this is good buddy what this
amounts to is what's the value of the
constant like I don't know what it is
but I could find out finding out the
value of the clothespin that corresponds
to finding out which premièred my up to
okay so I'm going to use this
information to solve for C
that's what I'm after okay so how will I
do that how can this information help me
find out this guy yeah very good huh
gonna substitute it right back into this
guy because that will turn these tunes
no this this into another and then see
will just be the remaining pretty girl I
can solve for it so let's do that so
here so y is equal to x squared plus X
plus BC so I'm just gonna do a straight
substitution I've got five for y I've
got negative two squared plus negative
two plus C so you can see I'm gonna
solve for this right what am I going to
get over here on the right hand side
that's 4 minus 2 which is 2 okay so just
carefully everything out I get it closer
to 3 right now I'm not finished I'm
gonna use that and I'm gonna bring her
back into what Y actually is right
that's the arch I'm looking for
the closet is just the means to an end
right so now I can say example y equals
x squared plus X plus that particular
cluster now I know which pretty another
laughter my tits well if I call that 3
okay there you go that's the one I want
and the rest of the room irrelevant
right they but none of them they're
gonna pass through this particular point
that has been named okay
and just because I got lucky all right
now I want you to have some time to work
with this idea particularly because like
I said you kind of have to mentally
shift gears a little bit like wait I'm
so used to turning you know X X cubed
into 3x squared right execute is not
going to turn into 3x squared if it's
the derivative right what's going to
happen just quickly rehearse with me
I mean increase the power
so it becomes fall and then I'm going to
divide right plus my constant so you
need to get used to this mental shipping
it's not complicated like it's not any
harder than what you did before it's
just your so your brains in a particular
tracks you've got to now learn to be
movable